By fall.
The time has come for families
across the far south
to leave their summer homes.
But some are far from ready to say goodbye.
After almost a year apart
time together is precious.
Like us,
it can take years for albatross
to find their soulmate.
And long distance romances
take work.
But it's all been worth it.
At 75 days,
wandering albatross
have one of the longest
incubations of any bird.
Until their egg hatches
they'll have to feed in shifts.
But our oceans are more dangerous
than ever before.
Every goodbye
could be his last.
And he's gone.
Each year
he's having to fly further and further
to find enough food.
Testing their relationship
to the limit.
Failure
to provide is now ending more and more
of these epic
love stories.